la caisse annoncé que damas et dix à
billes à aller au saut thomas lautaret
ne sont qu'à sion et à cointe sy abou
ahmad a minoré pour aider les convertis
tv consignes à tva la justice herman tu
as prêtres du diocèse de lyon qui a
notamment mis en place une troupe scoute
dans les années 70 jusque dans les
années jusqu'en 91
cette troupe scoute représenter 400
enfants et
et donc
cet homme là était un pédophile qui a
réitéré en plus pas dire ainsi divise
parce qu'il n'a pas été préalablement
condamné mais qui a réitéré des actes
d'agression sexuelle jusqu'à des faits
de viols sur des enfants mais cet homme
là en fait a toujours informé sa
hiérarchie de ses déviances sexuelles
donc ça fait 60 ans 50 ans que le
diocèse de lyon c'est que cet hamlet un
prédateur sexuel
[Musique]
je n'ai encore 2 la semaine dernière qui
se sont manifestés c'est très longue la
démarche est très très longue
en fait et beaucoup d'hésitations et la
proche et très est très longue
pour nous contacter
[Musique]
le sujet c'est quand on sait qu'un homme
est dangereux pour la société
c'est de prendre la décision d'avoir
l'inconscience de se dire on va le
déplacer on va le mettre ailleurs
c'est ça la problématique
réfléchi et j'ai réfléchi très
sérieusement à retirer ma plainte contre
repreneur parce que ce procès ne
m'intéresse pas en fait moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est que demain des gamins
ne vivent pas ce que nous on a vécu
c'est ça ma motivation est ce qui
m'anime
et ce qui a animé ce projet associatif
c'est ça c'est de dire que il ya un
système il va falloir l'accepter il ya
un système mondial et des gens dans
cette institution qui se connaissent pas
et qui refont exactement la même chose
dans des proportions massives et qui
nous expliquent qu'ils n'ont pas bien
compris la gravité
parce que c'est que ce que c'était que
la pédophilie je ne peux pas fermer les
yeux et passer à autre chose en fait
j'ai l'obligation d'agir sinon je
je cautionne sinon je je je deviens ce
que je dénonce
[Musique]